it's such - my notes
well
and that's not the only thing that he
touched
Oh cut hey boom guy let's chat [ __ ]
okay keep this this is a thing called a
frame and your boom look at it
do we try not to do that okay next time
let's reset huh
ridiculous what do you know we set over
there over there we set we set over
there well I need something your
diamonds will make you feel better
excuse me hi I guess I was like uh oh
and a necklace joke how about this one
yeah oh okay she posted can we fix the
lighting in here please so dark
[Music]
yes yeah yes I love this flight too bad
there's only one but it's okay let's run
this from the top take it from the top
though huh yeah people
all right cool let's get on our marks
roll sound
you good okay and action you touched it
why not
girl
and that's not the only thing that eat
it no no Steve she's better marks you're
right you're right but I love this
framing I love it I love it you know
what let's take a second and redo this I
love this
what's the matter Peter I don't see my
name on it
Oh all right everybody on your marks
okay guess who's the director everybody
on our marks
and action
[Music]
who touch my nose
yeah and that's great and forget you're
so talented you know I cut cut
excellent guys beautiful listen let's
run that back more lighting on Peter
this time uh I'm gonna go take a [ __ ]
real quick
[Music]
[Music]